There was a man here,
but he’s disappeared as you look.
There was a dog here,
but he’s vanished, as you watch.
There was a street here.
It’s not here,
you keep looking.
There was a notice–
there’s one now–
of bouncing away.
There is information
about the vanishing point
of a street.
One.
I had invited Vito and Maria
on the occasion
of MoMA PS1 turning forty.
And I thought, who is an artist
who really galvanizes
the artistic energy and innovation
and groundbreaking nature
of going into the city
and dealing very early on
with new media
and new approaches.
So who would that artist be,
who is like groundbreaking,
experimental and is challenging
like this institution is
and still is forty years later?
Vito, do you recognize the street?
– I do, I mean but it’s different now.
– Yeah.
Forty or fifty years later.
I hope we’re going to open.
And I hope we’re going to open
with a project all of us want to do.
What can our crew
most effectively do today
so we’re moving forward?
– Finishing this.
– Yeah. Great.
Yeah, we’re still far away
from being finished, great.
I still don’t understand
why some things were white on black
and some things weren’t.
From where we’re standing
why?
Why wouldn’t somebody call you?
He was very hesitant to do the show,
because Vito does not like
to go back to his past.
I was adamant that we had
to incorporate architecture, design
to say, look,
this is what Vito is doing now.
Everything is very calculated
because Vito and I
are both very meticulous.
I wanted to make
some kind of statement
that comes from me.
So “Where We Are Now,”
whereas, “Where Are We Now,”
is too flimsy.
We can trick it,
because then in the parentheses is
“Who Are We Anyway?”
This whole text is thirty six pages.
There’s no way
we’re going to fit thirty six pages.
– Not at all.
– So I think we just fit,
– what fits in that space basically.
– Exactly.
It’s hard for me
not to say something else.
I would like to get it done by Friday.
Yeah, yeah. No, we need to
start writing tomorrow
if we’ve got
any chance of getting it done.
He’s very particular about
the spaces in between paragraphs
and the width of some columns
being wider and some being thinner.
One, two, three, four, five.
You think you’ll get it done in time?
He’s going to come by Sunday.
I guess we’ll see what
happens at that point.
But we have until
one o’clock tonight.
It is the day in as much as we...
It’s a moment of truth
and we will see
if the show actually opens.
We have worked
for three-and-a-half months
in the exhibition space
and all of a sudden
we have constructed something.
So architecture
has been realized and produced.
I’m about to press
the send button on the invite.
– Shall I really do that?
– Yes.
– Good. Vito?
I sent it to three-and-a-half
thousand people
who are showing up here on Sunday.
We have to do that. Now it’s out.
– Is that really true?
– Yes.
Three-and-a-half.
We better have something.
“Seedbed,” for me,
was such a historical piece.
It really grounded you,
no pun intended,
but it grounded you
as an artist in everybody’s eyes.
You changed the art world.
Maybe I made a mistake
in grounding myself with that.
A big mistake
was everything came from one point.
I really screwed up the piece.
You screwed up the piece,
still you made art history.
–Are you a perfectionist, Vito?
I try to be, but I fail.
I really felt like
I had nothing to do with art.
Art to me was,
kind of fakery.
I despised calling what I did art.
I thought of them as activities.
I think many
of his early instruction pieces
and early investigations
are literally a premonition
and anticipation of social media.
Of documenting
every single moment of your life.
But then you see Vito
more than forty years earlier
creating a selfie or a self portrait.
I think Vito Acconci very often
is about seducing the camera
and that is what Snapchat or
Instagram or YouTube very often are.
From seeing Vito,
you kind of get the sense
wait a second,
I can be alone in my bedroom
and film myself
doing whatever I want to do.
You need me!
I think Vito made it more comfortable
and he made it
not a big deal in a sense.
I only know
there’s got to be somebody.
There’s got to be somebody
watching me,
somebody who wants
to come in close to me.
I hope that people
will be able to experience Vito
from the past and into the future.
I think he is sort of...
I don’t want to say shell shocked,
but maybe that’s the right word.
He has sort of a PTSD
of 1968 to 1973.
The people have kept him in a prison.
He feels like he hasn’t
been able to expand
into what he wants to be right now.
I can’t imagine what it would be like
to always be associated with that
when actually you’ve moved on
from that a little bit
and you’re interested
in doing something else perhaps.
So that’s why maybe
this has been quite an interesting
or difficult process for him
because he is trying to somehow
put that back into something
that is relevant maybe for him now.
It always bothers me though that,
I don’t think as many people
think of me as doing architecture.
And that kind of saddens me.
I wonder with you Vito,
if you ever in the evenings sit down
and are a little proud
of all the amazing
achievements you’ve made.
I’m always trying to do something new.
I always hoped that
I never do something
that is a second attempt at a project
that I’ve already done.
And I would think
if this doesn’t mean anything,
I wouldn’t do it.
I think you’re too hard on yourself.
I don’t know.
I’d rather be hard on myself.
I have made my point.
I make it again.
It.
Now you get the point.
– It’s beautiful.
– Wow!
– I think it’s really amazing.
– Oh my God.
Yeah, it fills the walls.
It’s so nice.
Thank you so much.
– Are you happy?
– Yes.
– I’m mighty proud.
– Really?
Because it’s I,
who should be proud of you.
I think if you look at the poetry
and you look at the reading,
the focus is very much more
on not stopping than on detail.
And by declaring
certain details to be worked out,
it’s guaranteed
that the process goes on.
I think that’s very important.
The process for Vito
is like a Möbius strip.
Something that’s continuous,
and that keeps on going.
It’s never ending. That’s Vito.
It’s almost like he wants
to make it better last time he did it.
It didn’t exist before
in this sort of way,
so I think he’s being
quite particular about it
and wanting to translate
what he did before.
But when you’re making something,
it can change.
When it’s finished and it’s made,
then it is what it is.
Something changing means it’s alive.
I am here.
Again.
Three days and three nights.
And then we got,
until last night we got there.
So it will take two more days
and that will take three more nights.
It’s beautiful, right?
I looked up at it,
and then it was down,
when I looked there,
every which way
until I had asked, “What?”
After it disappeared,
it did.
Vito, Maria, your show is incredible!
Aren’t you very happy?
He loves it.
– Don’t you love it?
– Yes.
It makes me feel hopeful
that the way the show ends
with this diving board,
but doesn’t really.
This is a diving off
point for the future.
That’s an interesting point
to learn about Vito –
how much of Vito’s work
is a self-portrait.
I think the exhibition is a portrait
of Vito Acconci 1976,
and it’s a portrait of Vito Acconci,
2016, forty years later.
It’s a double portrait.
I congratulate all three of you!
– That monitor should be down.
– Yes, I saw that.
You are right.
I saw that too, you are right.
I appreciate
that a whole new audience
is getting to know Vito.
He is getting the attention
that he has always deserved.
Big toast to Vito and Maria.
Do you have any positive feedback?
Well it’s hard to tell now
because they had to
really change things
and the way
they wanted to change things
was to have black print
on white paper.
And I think
that was kind of a mistake.
Was there anything
you liked about the show?
The things I liked were...
I think where we tried
to do some things too fast.
And when you’re trying
to do something too fast,
there’s always a kind of problem
and they just ran out of time.
Right, so that’s something
you didn’t like.
But what about,
is there anything that you did like?
Say one positive thing. Say it.
– Well no... I mean...
– Shhhh
– I already said that...
– No you didn’t.
I kind of can’t because
I can’t see it.
I am here as I go by.
Again.
He’s constantly growing.
He’s constantly changing.
Because nothing
is ever good enough for Vito.
I don’t know
what I’m going to do next.
Ideally I’d like to do a project
that goes on forever.